when you're doing the eric andre show
you you've kind of made a pact with
yourself that
you'll change your look every season
that you do it yeah and then i read
there was
i'm always fascinated by this there was
one season where you said [ __ ] it man
i'm gonna shave my head and i'm gonna
gain like
60 pounds and i'll come out and i'll do
that
well i heard that you tried but you
couldn't do it like you gained 20 and
that was about all you could gain
yeah i was just eating peanut butter
jelly sandwiches and pizza at night
every night before bed just trying to
was that fun
it was fun for like a week and then you
get really depressed
and cranky and irritable and your body's
changing
and but you're a young guy do you ever
say to yourself like [ __ ] i'm gonna
i'm gonna gain 60 pounds i'm not going
to get laid like i'm getting laid when
you're 38 is very important to you you
know what i mean so like
you know it's a fine line you know
yeah i mean that's the risk i was
willing to take
do you have no ego i mean do you sit
there and say i don't give a [ __ ] if i'm
not attractive to women i just
want this funny to go on no you are
depressed you are definitely depressed
while you're going through it you just
know it's going to be funny later
at this part i didn't understand you
said one season
i'm not going to shower for the entire
season of the show yeah
i want to smell bad it's like you're a
farm animal
yeah yeah it's not great for my sex life
my creative choices are not when you
decided to do that
were you seeing someone at that point i
was and i also
grew out my fingernails really long for
that season
i had like like guinness world record
like freddy krueger
nails so it was very hard to be intimate
with my lady at the time
what was your thought about not
showering though like i mean
it's not a visual thing well i wanted to
just
reek and i wanted to not wash the um
suit so i would sweat in the suit a lot
i grew up my nails and i like didn't
brush my hair i just wanted to like
not just for the guests to just be like
this off-putting talk show host but like
also when i'm in the streets
i want people to be like this isn't
crazy person
and i have to like it's like you have to
be like a method actor
by design of the hidden camera nature of
things you know what i mean you really
have to be convincing when you're doing
pranks
or people will be like oh yeah right
you're [ __ ] with me
so it's it's about commitment you know
you